but we're going to begin with the
midterms a lot of people think the
country's going in the wrong direction
we're at a Crossroads now with four days
to go until election day got a foggy
picture there of the Capitol and the
Outlook in terms of who's up Who's down
foggy as well Ed O'Keefe and Robert
Costa have been on the campaign Trail
for us covering races that could
determine who controls the house and the
Senate we're going to begin with Bob who
spoke with Democrat John Federman in
Pennsylvania
we have a stark choice between somebody
that is here with a career that actually
served Pennsylvania compared to somebody
that's here just to use Pennsylvania
Pennsylvania voters could decide which
party takes control of the U.S Senate we
have families all over the Commonwealth
worried about crime in our interview
John Federman contested Republican
memade's claim that he soft on crime I'm
the only candidate in this race that
actually had Hands-On kinds of
experience against fighting against
Crime and I made gun violence as really
at the center of all of my focus
betterment who's recovering from a a
stroke and may used a closed captioning
device during the interview with the
stenographer typing out the questions in
real time some voters we've spoken to in
recent days say they still have some
doubts about your health
what would you say to them to convince
them otherwise I would say we have shown
more and shared more kinds of medical
evaluation more than virtually anyone
unless you're running for for the
president and it's it's also been a
challenge for my family as well too like
most Democrats running this cycle
fetterman has had to contend with voters
dismayed by the High Cost of Living what
do you say to them what I would say to
them is that you need a senator that is
going to push back against corporate
greed and the kind of price gouging as
well true Oz says Democrats policy these
are to blame so if you think it's bad
now imagine when Joe Biden is
intimidating you into spending trillions
more dollars than we've already thrown
away and that your children's money
you're wasting and driving inflation up
but vetterman says he'll be proud to
stand alongside the president and former
president Barack Obama this weekend they
reject extremism these are the kind of
values that I think are the right
direction that we need to be going uh in
about this race